[Music]
there's a sense of achievement to be in
the steel worker and I think I'm
producing Quality Steel
I remember a sense of Pride when my
father got me the furnace Foreman
at night if the furnaces have been
toughed you know the glow of that can be
seen for for miles and bones
I just couldn't believe what I was
saying the noise
vibrations all through your body the the
lightning show the firework display
[Music]
fear is that if anything happened to the
steel industry what we got at the moment
that even that will go on that's a worry
imagine a life without steel and and
there's not a lot left
it's not clear that the UK has a
competitive advantage in steel and that
we we physically don't necessarily need
a domestic industry
it's an industry that's been in crisis
as long as anyone can remember but now
Britain the country which invented
modern steel making might plausibly
become the first developed economy to
allow it to go extinct raising a few
questions how did it come to this does
it really matter and do we even need a
steel industry anymore
[Music]
foreign
at the portal but still works in South
Wales the blast furnace is about to be
tapped
this is how we make most of the metal in
this country melting a mixture of iron
ore Limestone and coking coal into the
furnace and draining out the bottom to
produce this red hot pig iron which will
later become Steel
as industrial sites go there's nothing
quite like it that firework effect you
can see behind me into those tiny little
pieces of molten iron coming out from
the base of this Blast Furnace inside
there temperatures over 2 000 degrees
that's what you need to turn Solid Rock
into molten liquid iron that's pouring
out from the base of it but the Striking
thing about this is actually iron is
kind of the side product here for every
ton of Steel produced here there are two
tons of carbon
still is the backbone for the modern
world if it's not made of steel it's
made with steel but this site is the
single biggest greenhouse gas emitter in
the country and the owners tartar steel
want to pull down the furnaces and
replace them with a Greener alternative
looking for a model where the
a full circular economy but we are
talking about billions which will need
to be invested and also about NLP policy
and they want taxpayers to Bear some of
that burden the afternoon for a support
we're asking for investment
at this point of time governments in
Europe are throwing billions of money
into our competitors industry in Germany
in France in Spain and we are only
asking for a similar deal they want to
have fairness a fair deal for our
communities for our people
from piles of iron ore and coal in South
Wales
to piles of scrap in South Yorkshire
this is the other way we make steel here
the main ingredient is old parts from
cars and appliances it is for want of a
better word recycling
then report Tolbert Rock was being
turned into lava here this is quite
literally lightning
[Music]
bolts of the lightning that are turning
solid steel into molten metal and that
thunderstorm that's actually the
greenest way we have a baking still in
this country right now but of course it
uses untold amounts of power
this extraordinary process is how they
make most of their Steel in America
these days in the UK not so much the UK
has one of the largest I'd say scrap
must be simple piles in the developed
world
and right now we export over half of
that to other countries to turn into
steel to bring back into the UK
so what we do here is we make use of
that I'd almost call it natural recycled
resource
so why aren't we making all our steel
this way a big part of the answer is
that this country has higher power costs
than nearly every other developed Nation
I would say from a scrap source as I
mentioned earlier it's a good place to
have an electric Arc furnace
you know this is the right kit to have
to make steel in general but in this
country but from an energy standpoint no
then the day I think we're still about
30 percent above what the continent is
now up until recently the conventional
wisdom was that the kind of Steel that
you make in electric Arc furnaces was
pretty low quality but actually what you
can see bubbling behind me there and
that Ladle that's pretty high quality
stuff it's going against automotives
they also make steel that goes into
aircraft landing gear
every three seconds there's an airplane
landing somewhere on steel man at this
site there's a lot of pride in that kind
of statistic if you like
I can't see how anyone would think that
manufacturing and and making steel is
going to make you any uh any weaker it's
it's a strong it's the strength that we
need to uh we need to embrace
the problem is power costs make it
really difficult for the UK to compete
and the upshot is that no other country
in the world say Venezuela has seen as
sharper form in steel production leading
some to ask do we need a steel industry
at all
certainly not clear that taxpayer money
should go towards massively subsidizing
a steel industry it is tragic for people
who are in an industry that isn't
necessarily sustainable I think
ultimately there's a risk here that
you're selling people a lie that the
longer you use taxpayer money and light
very large amounts of taxpayer money for
a very small number of jobs you're
You're Building people up in a sector
that doesn't necessarily have a as clear
a feature as you want and that that
money I think could probably better use
focus on those individuals ensuring that
they can get the skills they need to
retrain into whatever the future
Industries are for the UK
even the person who'll make the decision
over whether to help the industry
doesn't sound all that enthusiastic
nothing is ever nothing is ever a given
there's a big bigger picture around
steel Beyond should we just uh save this
particular company or help this
particular community
in Port Albert they're used to this kind
of speculation iron runs deep through
the veins of the workers and families
here my grandfather worked in the core
governs my father worked on a blast
furnace and my boy who worked in the
cold Mill their notes the town has
shrunk you know the the you look at
Station Road the shops and that it's not
what it used to be but we'd like to hang
on to what we got there and the fear is
that if anything happened to the steel
industry is going to drive youngsters
out the portal but it's going to drive
people out the portal but you know
they're going to be looking for jobs
elsewhere and that for the first time in
ages there is a vision of economic hope
competing with the familiar visions of
Despair this town will soon be part of a
Freeport with the steel mill at its
Center
and tartar says it can produce some of
the steel needed from its Mill today the
hot metal which began in the blast
furnace gets converted into Steel in
this basic oxygen converter
before being cast into big fat slabs
and then squeezed and flattened into
long thin coils after some more pressing
and galvanizing those coils eventually
find their way to this plant outside
Wolverhampton
so we deliver at the next day into an
hour slot service from this facility
this is still very much just in time
right now oh absolutely I mean that's
what the you know the car makers want to
want to be able to do we want to have
the flexibility
the steel makers this is the end of the
line what was once Rock and then lava is
now a finely honed product that will
soon be part of a car
what we talk about still a lot of the
focus understandably is on the beginning
of the process that moment in the
furnace with all the fire but arguably
just as if or more important is this bit
the end of the process there are more
than a thousand different varieties of
Steel lots of different grades Alloys
high strength stuff but that raises a
question is person actually making the
right kinds of Steel
out in the North Sea you'll find some of
the biggest steel structures in the
world these wind turbines contain
hundreds of thousands of tons of steel
but here's the thing barely a fraction
of that metal comes from the UK this is
almost all Asian steel shipped in from
the other side of the world
the amounts of Steel coming from the UK
are very low we have no supplier for
this UK that is supporting on the tower
we have
I've been in contact with many steel
makers from the UK over the years over
and over again but the main challenge is
that none of the suppliers really was
capable of delivering the steer that we
need for the tower
that's right we simply don't make the
right kind of Steel the heavy plates you
need for the Tower actually that's not
entirely true there is a liberty plant
which makes them in Scotland but well
here's what happened when they try to
use their Steel in a turbine
we've been wanting to build
wind a wind farm with our own steel
coming out of out of DL up in Scotland
it's not cost competitive so between the
energy number one and number two what
the Imports are if we were going to
develop our own wind farm
it's cheaper to bring it in right now
it's on the line and it shouldn't be on
the line
perhaps by now you're starting to see
how tricky this is we can't make the
steal for our wind turbines because our
energy costs are so high and those
energy costs are high in part because we
spent so much to subsidize these wind
turbines now the steel industry wants
its own subsidies to decarbonize to
survive
what kind of survival
it was 20 odd thousand people working
there at one stage it was about twelve
thousand when I started there no we
don't I think it's about just over four
thousand
the brutal reality is that even if Tatar
gets the money it wants to replace these
glass furnaces with electric Arc
furnaces many more jobs will go we
understand the current plans imply a
Workforce of a mere thousand people
the country which gave the world the
industrial revolution could be among the
first to replace all its blast furnaces
with Greener Alternatives
but the upshot will be even fewer people
working the iron